you two just tied the knot on television
how are you feeling
what a ride i'm thrilled and
so happy that we can talk about it oh my
gosh rock how are you feeling this was
such a big moment
i'm overwhelmed i'm overwhelmed
in the best way i hope absolutely oh
yeah for sure
i now pronounce you husband and wife
please if you'd like let's talk all
about this wedding um that day you show
up to set
kind of walk me through what the energy
and the tone was like that day
i remember that we were originally going
to shoot the wedding in front of the
mercantile
when martin and i are putting on the the
flowers on each other
that was we were in the mercantile
because we were then originally
at the way it was scripted we were going
to go out and get wet on the front
stairs of the mercantile
and it was going to be outside of course
weather permitting that did not happen
so we ended up getting a church wedding
which was
kind of cool as well but it was a change
for sure i don't know if it was uh
made on the day or the day before or
something like that
was it the day before yeah lawrence
knows
i know the exact timeline of when this
all went down so loretta tell me a
little bit about that day was there
a certain magic in the air that day did
it feel a little different
yes it did i mean i was so
excited and and i am personally married
too and so it did start to bring back
so many memories of my own wedding and
my own
feelings of like oh my goodness this is
such a
big change for these characters like
everything is going to be
somewhat different now you know getting
married and so
i felt so cared for the hair and makeup
team
they made me truly feel like a queen
on that day even though it was
make-believe they still made me feel so
uh special and beautiful and it was
lovely loretta you are a queen in real
life and florence is absolutely a queen
as well
i want to talk a little bit about
tradition were there any bridal
traditions that you enforced on the day
of i will say
that johanna newmarch who plays molly
which is florence's
best friend we are team flomo you know
forever when we went for lunch the
transport that was taking us back to
circus for where we were going to eat
when we opened the door of the van my
wedding dress was stuck in the door
and i think johanna and i
had a full like bride and bride's best
friend moment like oh my goodness this
is a crisis this is the crisis we need
to fix it we need to mix this right now
and honestly johanna in true form she
fixed it
she was like don't leave don't leave
she's stuck at the door
i think so and she helped me get that
dress
out of the sliding door and away we went
and i said oh my goodness this is like a
like a real wedding day fiasco
wow okay and did the dress make it out
okay any threads pulled
no miraculously no i didn't know how i
was gonna tell barbara that there had
been an
accident i don't think she would have
taken it well it all worked out but
johanna really came to the rescue
i appreciate you all so much can you
tell me
any secrets about the dress we tried a
lot of different
things with the waistband of the dress
that ended up being just like beautiful
flowing pieces
but at one point there was going to be
like a big bow you know on the back
and uh i don't know i feel like with the
hair
it might be just too much of a risk for
florence
so we ended up with what we ended up
with which was so beautiful and that's
actually a separate piece
so i really loved that you know we
certainly talked a lot about hair and
makeup
and jewelry and all of all of that kind
of stuff we
knew that florence's hair had to be a
really big
transformation because you know she's a
very
somewhat uptight and put together
controlling character who always wears
her hair up
and so for florence that would be a
really big risk to have her head down
and flowing and so feminine and
everybody was gonna look at her which i
think was quite confronting
to her as well and the hair piece that
um that ended up in florence's hair we
absolutely collaborated on what that
would be
and it was a really a really fun
experience so yes i did get to have a
say well you looked absolutely gorgeous
and
stunning and breathtaking and you too
rothgar you looked so
sharp and so handsome did you have input
in what your character wore and what the
boutonniere looked like
i had some really really uh strong ideas
what the hair should look like for ned
they felt it i nailed it yeah they were
everybody came together and it was
beautiful they were just turned out just
the way i'd imagine
they just told me what to put on and i
wore what they told me
which is you know classic ned so that's
fine before we get into the actual
wedding ceremony i want to talk about
some of the
touching moments that we saw leading up
to the big day
may i ask that we share our first kiss
here in private let's
uh let's make it a good one
tell me about why that was important to
netted florence
well i think because it's a public
display and they're fairly
public people but private in lots of
ways too i asked actually asked loretta
rothgar asked loretta hey listen do you
want to try this kiss
like you and i like somewhere so that
and she was like no no i want to do it
on the day live in front of that crew it
is lawrence and
ned's first kiss and there's such a sort
of
innocence to these two characters trying
to navigate their way
through this new and second chance that
love which is really endearing
let's make it loretta and rothgar's
first time too and see if that adds any
you know special secret pixie dust you
know to
to make it extra extra real well i think
you both did a fantastic job because i
even get goosebumps thinking about what
a magical scene it was
loretta i want to talk to you about a
moment that absolutely
got me choked up florence she shows all
the ladies her
stunning bridal look and she asks for a
moment alone with molly
you really are the sister i never had
you're the mother i forever wanted and
you are the friend that i have always
needed
how did you get through that monologue
without getting tearful yourself
well the first take i did not
so i couldn't even get the words out
it was kind of like the the last episode
of friends when
monika and jenna and jennifer aniston
and rachel are
saying they're crying that they can't
even get the words out and they don't
even understand each other
it was like that
you know deidre that scene between molly
and florence
is that's actually the reason why i
really wanted to do one calls the heart
because i wanted to do a show that
celebrated the sisterhood
of true friendship between women who
support each other
and who love each other and who are
right there and know their best friends
so so well it was such a beautiful way
for florence to be able to give
tribute to molly and everything that she
means to her so
that's actually my favorite scene of the
episode
you've walked beside me picking me up
whenever i've stumbled along the way
and you have done the same for me
how much of that is florence and how
much of that is actually
loretta in that moment telling her
friend johanna how much she means to her
absolutely i mean where does one start
and the other one
begin yes that's absolutely you know
loretta talking to johanna
and also loretta talking to all the
women of the world
you know to say love your best friend
and appreciate your best friend and oh
my goodness
isn't it wonderful to have friends like
this
let's talk a little bit about the
wedding what was it like for you
rothgar to be standing there in the
moment watching loretta as
florence come down the aisle you know i
get choked up even thinking about it now
it's a strange
thing when you're because you're acting
and so you're like fine i
but moments have a realism to them and
when beautiful bride walks down the
aisle i have trouble containing myself
so
if there were tears in my eyes it was it
was for real i mean it's yeah it's a
beautiful lovely
moment and so it's actually it's a
lovely lovely thing to get to
experience as an actor because it's so
profound in some way
and i you know i think florence has been
on such a
personal journey throughout the seasons
but especially
in season eight and that was such an
important moment for her to walk down
the aisle because
it was really an embracing of loving
herself
and being like oh my goodness i am
walking into a whole new frontier of my
life
you know i think a lot of fans were
maybe anticipating
florence's son paul walking her down the
aisle
was that something that was ever part of
the conversation we had sort of made the
decision
that because katie was sort of joining
the wedding party
later that he would already be there and
i sort of felt
like you know florence has really been
on this
sense of empowerment throughout this
this episode sort of feeling really
insecure and because she's been
searching for that one thing that nobody
can do for her but herself which is
self-compassion
and self-love and i really just felt
like well her walking down the aisle is
a good manifestation of that
because she's saying i'm gonna let my
light shine here i am
yes as molly said huzzah it was such an
amazing moment right
that's right rothgar i want to ask you
you guys decided to let
bill and joseph kind of take the lead on
doing the vows was that ever a
conversation that you had about maybe
reciting vows to one another how did you
guys come about um
how you did it i think again that was
scripted so there wasn't a lot of input
we just
i just i you know i just do what i'm
told i it would have been nice to do
some vows come to think of it yeah let's
let's reshoot that let's do something
hey look we we have time right now is
there anything you'd like to say
to your beautiful bride florence yeah
absolutely i remember
really specifically one of the first
times i was on set when it calls heart
season one and i was
blown away by how good loretta was i
remember
yeah no seriously i remember thinking
wow because she was so deeply in the
character and
and and just sean that let that be my
vow i was
i was blown away how good you were
that's so lovely thank you rothgar
i think that you are
an incredible talent a wonderful
collaborator
and i'm so privileged to get to work
with you and also get to know you
and call you a friend and man i hope
that we
get to have these fun times for many
more seasons to come i
really do you're you're a blessing in my
life and when calls the heart is a big
blessing in so many of our lives
we're here well i cannot wait to see
what the future holds my last question
for you rothgar
very hard-hitting question yeah did you
know
in all of your years of being on one
calls of the heart did you know that
your character's
ned's name was actually edmund no not at
all
you were stunned just like lee was
absolutely in fact there's a take where
i'm like what
edmond did you know his name was edmund
yeah yeah edmund i love it i'm an admin
that works
you